this video is brought to you by skill
share an online learning community for
creators with thousands of classes in
design business and more skill share is
giving away two months of premium
membership to help you explore your
creativity if you click the link in the
description below that's for the first
500 people only by the way more on them
in a bit in November 1910 Mexico
exploded triggered by a rigged election
the Mexican Revolution shook the nation
you've probably heard of its most famous
sons Emiliano Zapata and Pancho Villa
you probably even know its biggest set
pieces such as the 1914 US occupation of
Veracruz but how much dough most of us
know about the guy who started it about
the guy whose rule convinced hundreds of
thousands of Mexicans to take up arms
and fight to overthrow him born in 1830
Porfirio Diaz began life as a poor
nobody before rising to become his
country's absolute dictator starting in
1876 Diaz ruled Mexico with an iron fist
for over three and a half decades
leaving power only when swept from it by
the tides of revolution yet the story of
Diaz is more than just the story of an
autocrat although a strongman
Diaz oversaw one of the most sustained
periods of progress in Mexico's history
under his watch the country modernized
and transformed even as democracy was
trampled into the dust a devil to son an
angel to others this is the life of
Porfirio Diaz Mexico's gentlemen
dictator
[Music]
if you were a gambler the odds you'd
have given on newborn Porfirio Diaz one
day ruling Mexico would have been
somewhere in the region of several
quintillion to 1 when Diaz was born on
September the 15th 1830 it was to dirt
poor mestizo parents in the state of
Oaxaca if you're not up on your
terminology mestizo means mixed-race
Diaz's ancestors had been a combination
of white spaniards and indigenous Mixtec
people but while that might sound
interesting today and early Mexico it
was pretty much a guarantee that you
were going to spend your life wallowing
in poverty when he was just three or
five years old
Diaz's carpenter father died leaving the
family penniless the family was so poor
that they couldn't even afford shoes
there are tales that as a child
Diaz spied on a local cobbler trying to
figure out how to make shoes for his
family himself but then life wasn't a
picnic for anybody in 30s Mexico the
reason being that the country was just
embarking on a solid half-century of
chaos now in order for us to really
understand what's going on we need to
take a quick stroll through Mexican
history until only a decade before
Porfirio Diaz birth Mexico had been the
Viceroyalty of New Spain an outpost of
the Spanish Empire but that Empire had
lost its jewel in 1821 when New Spain
had won independence and declared itself
Mexico the early years of Mexico had
kind of been like watching a confused
middle schooler trying on various
personalities to see what sticks it had
been an empire it had been a republic by
the time Porfirio Diaz was old enough to
be spying on shoemakers though it had
settled into a much less welcomed form
Mexico was just a mess the trouble had
begun with 1828 disputed election what
started it as a democratic wobble soon
became the norm until Mexico was like a
big plate of political jello to give you
some idea just how shaky things were
between 1828 in 1857 the Mexican
presidency changed hands 50 times this
chaos was helped by a number of factors
both internal and external externally
there were all the European powers who
kept invading like the Spanish in 1829
or the French in 1838
generally those the facts than Mexico's
and liberals and conservatives would
rather focus on one another over
than actually governing the country then
there was Santa Anna
you might recognize Santa Anna from your
American history class he's the Mexican
dictator who laid siege to the Alamo and
lost taxes to a bunch of revolutionaries
but he was also Mexico's great political
survivor flitting between left and right
he tumbles in and out of the presidency
all the way from 1833 to 1855 adding to
just the general sense of chaos but if
the decade of Porfirio díaz's childhood
was characterized by a Mexico constantly
on the brink of crisis it had nothing on
what was gonna come next the 1840s would
see the start of a period when Mexico
was more or less constantly on fire and
when the entire country was nothing but
ashes Porfirio Diaz would be the only
person left standing
[Music]
there's a parallel universe where typing
Porfirio Diaz into Google will get you
nothing but a list of obscure Mexican
priests not in this universe though in
this universe Diaz's teenager attempts
to join seminary were interrupted by war
on April the 25th 1846 a group of
American soldiers deliberately wandered
into the disputed zone between Mexico
and the newly annexed state of Texas
when the Mexican border guards opened
fire the u.s. used it as a pretext to
launch a full-scale war if Mexico in
1846 was a wobbly stack of jell-o then
the Mexican American War was like a
hurricane blowing the entire pantry away
the American invasion caused the
government to collapse allowing Santa
Ana to seize the presidency for the
ninth time down in Oaxaca
fifteen-year-old Porfirio Diaz abandoned
the priesthood and instead enlisted in a
student militia to fight for Mexico's
honor but this wasn't the war Diaz was
destined to shine in heck he wouldn't
even become the biggest name from his
home in Oaxaca that honor would fall to
the Nieto Juarez born in 1806 Juarez was
from a fully indigenous family unlike
the mestizo Diaz and hadn't spoken
Spanish until he was 12 he was however
ferociously intelligent and had become a
lawyer and a leading liberal in Oaxaca
come 1846 Juarez had been elected state
governor just in time for the
mexican-american war when it became
clear that Mexico was destined to lose
that war Juarez made a stand and refused
to send any more young Oaxacan men to
die in Santa Anas ani
the result was Horrors landing a place
on both oaxaca unofficial list of
liberal heroes and Santa Anas very
official list of guys I'm totally going
to kill on February 2nd 1848 the war
ended before Eid as demobilized from his
student militia but rather than return
to the priesthood he instead returned to
Oaxaca
determined to follow in Benito Juarez's
liberal footsteps today Diaz is
associated with Mexico's Conservatives
but he started out learning at Juarez's
feet this gave Diaz a front row seat for
Santa Anas neck
vindictive move and yes intentional
emphasis on the dick there in 1853 Santa
Ana returns at the presidency for the
first time since the war only this time
he styled himself as his serene Highness
and he launched a brutal consolidation
of power a consolidation that included
kicking benito juarez out of the country
when Diaz heard his mentor was being
forced into exile
he was absolutely livid he marched down
to the town square where a referendum
was taking place on Santa Anas coup
watched over by Santa Anas armed
soldiers naturally and openly cast a
vote against the dictator in the chaos
that followed Diaz then managed to mount
a horse steal a gun and shoot his way
out of the town and off into the
mountains to ferment rebellion it was
both the most Mexican exit we've ever
heard of and also a really excellent
piece of political timing Santa Anas new
regime was as unpopular as a president
running for the 11th time tends to be
when others took up arms against him it
was clear his time was over in 1855
Santa Ana resigned and fled into exile
he would die in poverty in 1876 having
never regains the presidency in the
aftermath of Santa Anas two decade hold
on politics collapsing the Liberals took
power
Juarez came back to Mexico Diaz came
back down the mountains and everybody
cheered it should have been a moment of
calm a hard-earned bit of breathing
space after decades of chaos but this is
19th century Mexico we're talking about
and if there is one thing 19th century
Mexico was all about it was chaos when
the Liberals took power in the wake of
Santa Anas fall they weren't in the mood
for compromise they promulgated a new
hyper liberal Constitution that not only
guaranteed free speech and the right to
bear arms but also strips the Catholic
Church of its power and property
unfortunately for Diaz in Juarez Mexico
had a lot of Catholics a lot of
conservative Catholics now sure that
this Liberal government was destroying
their way of life and so we come to warn
under three thousand seven
ninety-two of this video the reformed
war and trust us it's not going to be
the last pitting liberals against
conservatives in a gigantic bloodletting
the reformed war bore louder former
sucked for just about everybody but it
didn't suck for Porfirio Diaz well I
mean it did physically in one early
battle he got shot leaving a festering
wound in his side that wouldn't heal for
a whole two years pretty nasty stuff
however politically the war paid
dividends when la reforma entered in
1860 with a liberal victory Diaz was
promoted for his heroism that meant that
he became a general just in time for the
French invasion of Mexico yes surprise
more war this time courtesy of Napoleon
the third after winning the reform war
benito juarez had retaken the presidency
and discovered that the country was
broke so he suspended all repayments of
foreign debts however one of those
foreign debts just so happened to be
yelled by france now under the
dictatorship of Napoleon's nephew Louie
Napoleon and if Napoleon the third had
inherited one thing from his uncle it
was his love of invading foreign nations
now we don't have time to go into the
French invasion in detail which is a
total shame because it's super
interesting and it involves Louie
Napoleon proclaiming a bull whiskered
Austrian man named Maximilian emperor of
Mexico if you want to learn more about
that you can check out our video on that
Maximilian for now though we're gonna
touch on one key date you've definitely
heard of and that would be Cinco DeMayo
[Music]
if you live north of the border there's
a good chance you only know Cinco DeMayo
is the day frat boys Don sombreros and
get absolutely hammered on tequila but
it was also the date of the Battle of
Puebla on May the 5th 1862 the Mexican
army faced the French in a battle where
they were outnumbered three to one
general Porfirio Diaz was technically
second-in-command of the Mexicans but
really it was thanks to him that we
celebrate Cinco DeMayo at all at the
climax of the fighting Diaz
single-handedly led a cavalry charge
against the French so daring was his
attack that the French line broke
resulting in a Mexican victory the
Battle of Puebla raised Porfirio Diaz
from being a near liberal icon to a folk
hero for the entire nation it helps that
Diaz followed his win up with escapades
like getting captured and breaking out
of prison twice by the time the French
abandons their Mexican adventure
Porfirio Diaz whilst in Mexico what Davy
Crockett is to America and he knew this
when the post invasion election of 1867
was held Diaz threw his hat into the
ring and he probably should have won the
only reason he didn't is that Benito
Juarez also ran while Diaz might have
been a folk hero Juarez was the nation's
wartime leader it was like FDR asking
the American public for his fourth term
of course Juarez was gonna win so Diaz
backed down he stepped out the race and
retired to a ranch in Oaxaca but here's
the thing
Porfirio Diaz in 1867 wasn't retirement
age he wasn't even 40 more than theirs
he was ambitious more ambitious than
Benito Juarez realized in less than a
decade that ambition was gonna take him
from Mexican folk hero to a bigger
dictator than Santana but just before we
get into how that happens let me take a
moment to tell you about today's
wonderful sponsor Skillshare unlike some
websites where you have to pay for
individual classes with a premium
membership from Skillshare you get
unlimited access so you can take as many
as you like which is pretty nice on
someone who'll just jump into a
particular part of a class extracts what
I need to know and then move on so those
sites we have to pay a fixed fee for
each individual thing then
ideal for someone like me now I've
talked about some of the classes that
I've taken before and I would still
absolutely recommend those like the
email productivity classroom Alexandre
Samuel or just generally building good
habits with a classroom Thomas Frank
they're both worth checking out for sure
anyway join more than 7 million creators
learning with Scotia skill share is
giving away two free months premium
memberships help you explore your
creativity just click the link in the
description box below oh that's only it
for the first 500 people and if you'd
like to continue your membership with
skill share it's super affordable it's
just ten dollars a month on an annual
plan again two months of premium
membership for the first 500 people
click the link below and let's get back
to it
[Music]
if we've done our job by now it should
be clear that Mexico in the mid 19th
century was near uncover nerble the
entire period from 1828 onwards had been
nothing but invasions Wars coos
dictators and imposed Emperor's when
Porfirio Diaz finally seizes power at
about five minutes time you might wonder
why no one goes into rebellion against
him why there is no great war against
his dictatorship well ask yourself this
if you had lived through all that chaos
would you really be itching for another
war for years after Diaz retired to his
ranch in 1871 another election rolled
around at this point Benito Juarez had
effectively been in power since la
reforma and their 15-year run it was
widely expected that he would step aside
to allow some fresh blood in someone
like I don't know certain mustachioed
general living on his ranch in Oaxaca
births no come 1871 Juarez stood for
re-election it was at this point that
Diaz snapped back in 1867 Diaz had been
deferential to his former patron this
election the gloves weren't just off
they'd been filled with dynamite and
shoved up Juarez's arse yes ran on a
platform relentlessly attacking Juarez
as a dictator in the making as another
Santa Ana
he made his rallying cry the phrase no
re-election and made limiting presidents
to a single term a key part of his
pledge
when Juarez still squeaked to victory
Diaz jumps on his horse picked up his
gun and rode back off into the mountains
to start another rebellion only it
didn't quite work while there were no
real battles the few skirmishes Diaz's
men participated in resulted in the army
wiping the floor with him it's entirely
likely Diaz would have just fizzled out
at fate not intervened on July the 18th
1872 Benito Juarez suffered a heart
attack and died at his desk
with Juarez gone a dude called Sebastian
alerted Tejada took over as president
luckily Leo was a guy who is all about
burying the hatchet
events similar to issued an amnesty for
everyone who'd taken up arms against
Juarez yes returned from the mountains
presumably thinking the next election
was gonna be in the bag and then 1875
rolled around and later decided to stand
for
election one of the major failures of
Diaz's anti juarez rebellion had been a
lack of funds so this time Diaz didn't
instantly declare himself in rebellion
but instead he travelled to the USA
there he arranged some meetings with
some very rich businessmen and let it be
known very subtly that were they to help
finance his bid for the top job he might
just start opening up Mexico to wealthy
American investors funding secured Diaz
then declared himself in rebellion under
his old no reelection slogan tooled up
with American guns and money
Diaz's army was now unstoppable but
there would be no major battle when Leo
saw which way the wind was blowing he
was all like you know what you can just
have the presidency Porfirio Diaz
finally became presidents of Mexico in
early 1877 one of his first acts was to
alter the Constitution to make
re-election illegal but while people in
1870s Mexico might have thought this
proved Diaz was for real with his slogan
from our vantage point in the 21st
century we can see just how hollow that
promise was Porfirio Diaz was now in
power and he had no intention of giving
it up Mexico would be under his perfumed
boot for the next 36 years
[Music]
[Applause]
if you've seen narcos you're recognized
Pablo Escobar's phrase Plata o Plomo
meaning silver all let's ieave work with
me and get rid Shore work against me and
get dead
well Porfirio Diaz had his own version
the period of Diaz's rule is known today
as the prefer yato and it's unofficial
slogan was pan or Paulo or bread or
stick the bread part 4 was for Diaz his
old enemies or others who might have had
the power to challenge him these guys
got not only showered with money but
guarantees that they could run their
power bases like personal fiefdom in
return all they had to do is not get any
ideas about becoming presidents the
stick part well that was for everyone
else peasants who objected to their
crops being taken by greedy elites
indigenous villagers worried about
haciendas stealing their land workers
who wanted to unionize well they all got
whacked with the porfiriato stick not
that this meant they were killed murder
wasn't Diaz's style he was too refined
for that no
what it meant was suddenly having all of
your property confiscated or being
deported to do back-breaking labor in
some far-flung region without your
family knowing where you were murder and
torture aside Diaz didn't really care
what happened to you that's because he
had a bigger project to focus on Diaz
wanted to make Mexico great again there
were two parts to his plan first Diaz
needed to ensure the chaos of the last
50 years was over so he sent waves of
police and vigilantes out into the
provinces Rey let them take care of the
bandits and highwayman in whatever way
they saw fit he had troublesome
villagers broken up their members all
separately shipped off to do hard labor
that Dundee has turned his attention to
the second part attract money into
Mexico at the start of the porfiriato
Mexico was deeply in debt with a poor
international reputation
Diaz made sure all of that changed he
made debt repayments a priority then
once people accepted that money invested
in Mexico wasn't money lost he went back
up north to see his American business
pals and present them with his grand
vision they would invest in Mexico and
Diaz would ensure they had monopolies
and that any troublesome workers were
dealt with using the Porphyrion stick
then in return these investors
modernize his country after all its
warring Mexico had almost missed out on
the Industrial Revolution there were few
rail lines and some provinces were still
so isolated that they were effectively
self-governing but not anymore
almost overnight railroad tracks sprang
up linking cities to ports and to the
u.s. a telegraph poles marched out by
the thousands connecting villages for
the first time to the modern world mines
opened which were digging up silver zinc
and copper by the bucketload all of this
created one of the most sustained
economic booms on record money was
suddenly pouring into a Mexico that was
suddenly safe what was the not to love
Diaz had Gamble's that after half a
century of mayhem Mexicans would accept
him trampling civil liberties in return
for law and order and a chance to get
rich and he was right the reason no one
rebelled against the porfiriato was
because no one wanted to but Diaz's boom
wasn't evenly distributed while the
elites the foreign investors and the new
middle class all got fat on Porfiry and
brent millions of peasants indigenous
and urban poor got nothing but the stick
then there was the hypocrisy in 1880
Diaz honored his pledged and stepped
down refusing to run for re-election
instead he installed a puppet presidents
and made sure that this puppet passed
just enough unpopular laws that come
1884 the people were begging Diaz to
return so Diaz did as the people asked
and then he amended the constitution to
make it legal for the president to have
unlimited terms so much for no
reelection
by 1908 the porfiriato was less a
dictatorship than it was a fact of life
Diaz was now the longest-serving ruler
in Mexican history making even Santa Ana
looked like a bit of a novice as the
porfiriato had ossified so - at the
country democracy had been dead so long
that no one could remember what it even
looked like land rights were a thing of
the past the rich kept getting richer
and the poor just kept getting poorer it
was against this backdrop of stagnation
and resentment that a 77 year old Diaz
gave the interview that would destroy
him
the Creelman interview by American
journalist James Creelman was meant to
be a puff piece it's certainly written
that way it's portrait of Diaz is so
sugar-coated that it should carry a
diabetic health warning but deep within
Creelman sycophantic prose was buried a
lands mine one that's when it detonated
would blow up the whole of Mexico and
amazingly it was planted there by Diaz
himself he was quoted as saying I have
waited patiently for the day when the
people of the Mexican Republic would be
prepared to choose and change their
government at every election I believe
that day has come
the words were vague meant to reassure
readers in the democracy loving us that
Diaz wasn't a bad guy but they also gave
everyone in Mexico the impression that
Diaz wouldn't stand in the 1910 election
you know that phrase when you're in a
hole stop digging
well Porfirio Diaz was evidently of the
better to dig straight through to
Australia school when everyone asked if
he really was gonna stand a slide and
let another president take his place he
was all like yeah sure why not
he stood by this all through 1909 as new
political parties emerged as a
pro-democracy businessman named
Francisco I Madero declared that he
would run under Diaz's former slogan of
no reelection Diaz even stood by his
words as Madera began campaigning in
1910 drawing enormous crowds of cheering
supporters maybe Diaz was so blinkered
that he assumed that he'd win in a fair
fight maybe he really did want democracy
in 1908 and then got cold feet as the
election approached either way the
result was the same right before the
election Francisco Madero was arrested
on polling day everyone was given a
choice of over Diaz or get a taste of
the old Porfiry instead
but you can't let a genie like democracy
out of its bottle and hope to just stuff
it back in Diaz had given Mexico
something unbelievably dangerous as
dangerous as handing the electorate a
loaded gun and placing the barrel
against his forehead he'd given them
hope on October the 5th 1910 Francisco
Madero escaped jail and fled into exile
in Texas there he issued the plan of
salary de potosí calling on the Mexican
people to rise up and overthrow Diaz at
long long last the Mexican Revolution
was here by the time it ended no one
would be left standing at all
you might already know that November the
20th is celebrated as Mexico's day of
revolution what you might not know is
that had you been alive on November the
20th 1910 you wouldn't have realized
that anything was happening
that's because almost nobody in Mexico
heeded Francisco Madero school in the
Capitol the papyri autocrine de Don like
nothing had changed but almost nobody is
not the same as nobody up in the north a
guy called poncho via decided to follow
Madero and get his revolution on what
began as a little bit of a disorder
quickly snowballed into an all-consuming
avalanche the army had got fat and lazy
on Porfiry and bread and forgotten how
to fight fear and his armies spends the
winter racking up victories by
mid-february Francisco Madero was back
in Mexico ready to lead the revolt yet
even now Diaz couldn't see the danger
that he was in he remains blind to it as
winter gave way to spring as Emiliano
Zapata --zz rebellion broke out in
Morales even as vias army laid siege to
Ciudad Juarez it wasn't until the city
was about to fall the Diaz seems to have
woken up to this looming threat but by
then it was too late
in early May Sierra Juarez fell at
around the same time the zapatistas
captured the city of quod block there
were only now two options
Diaz either resigns or he dug his heels
in and plunged Mexico into a bloody
civil war but Diaz wasn't a dictator
like serious a sad ready to drown his
country and blood to getting into power
he was a gentleman and gentlemen know
when to quit
on the 21st of May 1911 the Treaty of
Ciudad Juarez was signed paving the way
for an interim president and new
elections four days later on May the
25th Porfirio Diaz resigned the
presidency and boarded about de Europe
after 36 years the porfiriato was over
as he left Diaz famously declared of the
revolution Madero has unleashed a tiger
now let us see if he could control it
and a bit of a spoiler alert here he
totally couldn't in the next two years
Francisco Madero would become the first
president then be assassinated by
general Victoriano Huerta
Weta's coup would be what turns the
mexican revolution into an inferno
sparking the violence that killed
hundreds
of thousands but all that is a story for
another time aperio Diaz spent the last
four years of his life in exile in Paris
watching his former country disintegrate
possibly with sadness possibly with a
feeling of satisfaction that had been
right all along
Mexico really was uncover nerble Diaz
finally died on July the 2nd 1915 he was
buried in the Maupin a cemetery today
Porfirio díaz's reputation is still
unsettled on the one hands there are
those who point to the stability that he
brought to the real economic progress
that was made under his watch on the
other there are those who points the
millions left behind by the porfiriato
the millions abandoned until they got so
frustrated that violent revolution was
the only option
maybe both sides have a point without a
doubt Porfirio Diaz was a dictator
without a doubt he squandered the
security and progress's regime brought
by showering money on a narrow elite but
Diaz was also the linchpin of an entire
era of Mexican history a guy who ruled
for longer than anyone else
his story may not be a pretty one or
even an inspiring one but it's one we
need to remember for better or worse
without Porfirio Diaz modern Mexico
would be a very different place so I
really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe also why not check out a
new channel I'm working on called
business blaze it's a business theme
topics obviously and it's a little bit
more laid-back from this a little bit
more casual please check it out it's
linked to below and thank you for
watching
[Music]
you